we begin with the disastrous effects of
extreme weather in two parts of the
country in Kentucky flooding has caused
catastrophic damage while in California
the biggest and the second biggest
wildfires of the year have burned tens
of thousands of Acres at least 28 people
have died in Kentucky and dozens are
unaccounted for thousands have no power
the state's Governor says they could be
finding bodies for weeks and More Rain
Is On The Way Jim stratman of our
Lexington affiliate WKYT is in brecket
County Kentucky Jim good morning
good morning Nate as the waters have
receded over the weekend we're starting
to see more and more damage from the
flooding I'm down at a ball field and
you can see behind me the mud level
where that was left over by the flood
waters a week ago on Friday all of this
was completely underwater and now there
is damage as far as the eye can see
fences torn down mud and debris all over
the place and this is just an example of
what we're seeing all throughout Eastern
Kentucky we know that search and rescue
continues to be the priority for
officials down here in the eastern half
of the state but with heavy rains coming
that could add some complications as
seen as how already roads are heavily
damaged
the road to recovery is a daunting one
in Appalachia within 10 to 12 minutes I
hear the noise and I raise the window
and I seen the water and I knew I had to
get out of there rain triggered flash
flooding wiped out homes and
infrastructure leaving residents
shattered
I ain't got nothing
Governor Andy beshear expects the number
of deaths to rise in the coming days
after nearly a foot of rain fell on
parts of Eastern Kentucky
emergency crews have rescued thousands
of people in just a matter of days but
those efforts could last weeks as First
Responders struggled to access damaged
areas roads and bridges are a lifeline
and we have dozens of bridges that are
out that make it hard to get to people
for those who lost everything the
rebuilding process is only just
beginning I don't know where even where
to start what to do where to go just a
lot for I guess people around here to
take in it's it's more it's worse than
anything that we've ever seen and it's
not the first catastrophic event the
state has seen in the last year an
unusual December tornado killed 80
people mountain people were strong and
uh like I said it's not going to be
tomorrow probably not next month but I
think everybody's going to be okay it's
just it's just going to be a long
process
we do know that FEMA is down on the
ground here in several counties in
Kentucky and we are we do know the
females down to the ground here in
several counties here in Kentucky we
expect to learn a little bit more from
our governor a little bit later on this
morning Vlad
all right Jim our hearts go out to those
families just devastating thank you very
much